A couple of mistakes—right on tactics—I just want to remind you about.
I mentioned them earlier, but a common startup error on day one
is let's price on cost.
We know how much it takes to build our product.
We'll just add a markup that is a profit,
and therefore we have a price.
How hard can that be?
This is typically not a strategic way to price.
You might end up here, but boy there's a lot more moves on the table.
What you really want to think about is not just your internal economics,
but the customer insight that you actually have.
I want you do think about, yes, pricing on cost is maybe the first place we start,
but are we leaving a ton of money on the table?
Because the alternative to pricing on cost is pricing on value.
As we said earlier, you know now your customer segment's perception
of the value of your value prop.
Is it about time saved? New efficiency created?
Remember we talked earlier about pains and gains for this customer segment.
What is it that they value?
Why are you saving them a ton of money?
Now, customers don't necessarily feel that they want to pay this way,
but smart marketeers and smart startup executivies
can convince customers that instead of paying on cost
they really ought to be thinking about that your company is unique
and providing the most value—not just the cheapest product.